so victor uh are you going to be
dropping out of your phd to go and teach
at the university of austin i was
actually opening it up
you know what speaker's already jumping
ship and you know if it's too moronic
for him it's just got to be the most
moronic thing on this continent
he dropped out of what the university of
austin or the other
no he was an advisor i think when he
dropped out
[ __ ] just like the collection of just
massive sub stack morons i didn't see
that i didn't see that he dropped out
but i was actually thinking you know if
i can't get a job anywhere you know i'll
go teach at the university of austin no
problem i don't know if this was real or
not but i saw a tweet that said they had
like 5 000 applicants
for jobs
that's not surprising to me no that's
not surprising at all
so i'm on the website and beginnings
summer
2022 is
the forbidden courses
i could see i could see michael
millerman uh getting a job there i feel
like he'd be well-suited
what do you think the forbidden courses
are like there are only two genders or
something more like or like manliness
probably one on the bell curve at the
very least like manliness the bell curve
yeah like like the truth about the truth
about genetic differences among among
ethnic groups is christianity really uh
better than islam answer yes
yeah no their gender studies institute
is just like alpha beta gamma omega
sigma
they'll they'll teach like um yeah
harvey mansfield's book manliness
um
their website it's just like the school
of athens by raphael and oh yeah
committed
they have this like uh fantasy what's
that robin williams movie where he he
teaches them in the in the case
yeah he this is like dead poets society
for
for people who have been cancelled
yeah you should probably tell eric that
we started recording already so he'll he
should start recording hey eric we're
recording um
yeah i know i want to uh i want to teach
there i'm excited about it you know it's
going to be a a
you know a haven of uh real critical
thought so you know i can't wait
it's fantastic i mean are you white
enough to teach that back you're gonna
be such a [ __ ] alpha that none of us
will even be able to like
stand your presence uh the sheer
manliness that you'll exude
will be exhausting for all the rest of
us betas
on a serious note though i do some like
there's a part of me though that i'm
like
the kind of like
uh the dismissive snobby response to it
that we're having with that we're all
enjoying right now uh at the same time
like i feel a little bit like ah who
also like who gives a [ __ ] like let them
let them do their stupid little thing
and well they should have just called it
safe space university
since that's exactly what it is
no sorry sorry safe space university
asterix not actually an accredited
university basically yeah did i ever
tell you one of the funniest things uh i
ever encountered when i wrote those
articles for colette
you know colette like the right wing
magazine yeah yeah
so i wrote these articles because i
really wanted to kind of broach
left-wing ideas to a right-wing audience
and also just to see if i could do it
like could i can successfully convert a
few people uh which i did by the way
which is nice and i got emails about
that but like the number of people who
would post about things i wrote
endorsing marissa rawls being like this
is supposed to be an idw place we're not
supposed to be exposed to this kind of
thinking here uh i don't understand why
it's contaminating my perfect magazine
and every single time somebody did this
i would just retweet so
you want a safe space
to explore your ideas without the
possibility of them being contaminated
by anything that might actually make you
think differently about your positions
uh
because i have a lot of people on the
other end of the political spectrum that
i can introduce you to who can help you
out with that
well we learned long ago that any claims
for intellectual or argumentative
consistency by the intellectual dad web
will be shouted down by an army of
overly emotional 20-year-old
sigma males before they land anyway we
should uh we should get to the meat and
potatoes
[Music]
all right what did we talk about last
week
uh something we didn't talk about we
talked a
new consciousness oh it was uh
merlou ponti's critiques of
intellectualism and
uh empiricism mainly yeah that was good
stuff and these were these were some
interesting passages but yeah go ahead
and explain them all right so today um
a lot of kind of our our initial
approach to this
we're talking about merlot ponce's
phenomenology of perception
um
this is our fifth bit of content on it
because i did two videos on it over on
the uh
patreon if you want to see what we read
today even if you're not a patron you
can
find this post and i'll attach the links
to the sections
underneath that if you want to read what
we read anyway this is pillpod
60 something
and it's our actually a 109th episode
total
so um
this sounds a lot like navel gazing in
some cases where we're just
paying attention to attention itself
paying attention to human experience
itself
and what could
be misinterpreted there or get lost
there is that we are actually or that
merlou ponti was a marxist
and he had uh views of human history and
views of class consciousness that are
not
marxist specifically not like orthodox
marxists but they are phenomenological
and as a marxist he gave a
phenomenological
explanation or
account of what revolution could look
like and that's what we read today so
we're
we we took some weeks off of politics
and now we're reintroducing
a political episode but via
phenomenology
which is not honestly the way we usually
talk about
uh politics
but i gotta say this this guy just
[ __ ]
keeps nailing it over and over again
yeah i totally agree i mean this is uh
this is really good stuff we're kind of
jumping all over the place like we kind
of skipped some stuff to get to the
marxist and hopefully we'll be able to
go back to some of the the other stuff i
guess you were saying we're just taking
a little break from the non-politics to
get back into a little politics
yeah just just so that we're not navel
gazing you know because a lot of it
seems like naval gazing i think next
week we'll talk about poor old schneider
did you get did you get naval gazing uh
like did you get that feedback from from
people
oh no not at all i think i think people
are really liking this content but it
seems like
almost more meditative a little bit of a
retreat from
from the shared life world and paying
attention to your own
uh perception which could be
a little bit solipsistic
but here we're making the case that it's
not syllab system yeah right right right
so where do we start all right i'd like
to i'd like to start with a term victor
maybe i can kick this to you so i don't
have to uh keep talking sure
a term that i also know eric is fond of
uh inter-subjectivity
so how do we move from uh subjectivism
which is an accusation often leveled
against sart's account of freedom which
is like
history doesn't matter to me i'm an
anarchist nothing affects me i make all
my own choices
and how do we move from that to uh
inter-subjectivity here with miro ponzi
now i would say that probably sartre is
closer to marilla ponton than a lot of
people think i've read some convincing
stuff about that um and i think he
probably has a similar account of
interest objectivity he just likes to
emphasize this kind of radical freedom
point but
that's another here nor there um
yeah so inner subjectivity i think is
really just this idea that like our
subjectivity relies on on on for its own
existence and coherence on its
engagement with other subjectivities so
there is like
uh that like realities are created in
some ways worlds are created through
inner subjective engagement through
engagement with other subjects there
would be no subject
if not for that interaction between
subjects and i think you can see this
with language
i think language is like the location of
a lot of intersubjectivity in some ways
it wouldn't be possible if it was only
subjectivity language is only possible
inner subjectivity there's other
philosophers who pick up on this you
know who aren't in the phenomenological
tradition i think to some extent this is
really
you know uh wittgenstein's point when he
says that like you can't have a private
language you have to like that it it
depends on engagement with other
subjects and i think marilla ponti also
is thinking about how perception
and worldliness as we talked about in
previous life worldliness
as we talked about in previous part
episodes relies on that interaction um
you know and and i think that also is a
broader theme in maryland ponte
that like it's neither
this nor that it's like neither
objectivity or subjectivity it's neither
that like perception is neither like
some like coherent subject looking down
at the world but it's actually the world
and the subject interaction interacting
that somehow like perception
subjectivity is not on either side but
is like in the middle in the interaction
is the thing and that that goes for
subjects as well
i also wanted to stress how deeply this
can go uh particularly when it comes to
the language point so
wickenstein made a really nice point
where um he observed in one of the blue
or brown books i can't quite recall that
if i were to try to ask you
are you experiencing a pain right now
and you said yes
you might think of that as a purely
private experience right what could be
more private really than experiencing
pain but in fact there's an
intersubjective component to it because
you need the word pain to be given to
you to be able to articulate the point
both to yourself and others that i am in
pain
so in fact the life world and even our
ability to think uh in the language of
thought if you want to call it that
depends a great deal on the other yeah
of course we're not doing our episode on
wittenstein maybe we shouldn't and maybe
we should in the future um it should and
it's interesting because i think that
his concept of like forms of life might
have a lot of overlap with life world
but um yeah i think so but i would say
that uh yeah maybe we can save that
if a lion could speak we would not be
able to understand what it says
um and we should stress more intensely
we should also we should also stress
that
language is like the most evident form
of intersubjectivity
but it's not the only one even
perception itself the fact that
that there is a view that could be
anywhere
kind of implies what he calls the gaze
the gaze is not a hostile like it is in
uh psychoanalysis or can be i should say
in psychoanalysis the gaze is more like
any point of view can occupy any point
of sight
specifically and that implies that
you're not the only seeing perceiving i
shouldn't say seeing because that's only
one sentence but
perception could happen from anywhere
and because it does happen from other
places besides you it implies this
intersubjective perceptual world yeah
i guess um
i would ask here is so this existential
interpretation of subjectivity or
inter-subjectivity or whatever if we're
not even going to use the subject object
language he seems to say that it's
existing or co-existing
inter-human relations he uses terms like
that
now in the
in the classical sort of marxist
framework right we don't
we're not
directly inter-subjective we're our our
subjective relations are mediated by
products the products of of production
that
that we encounter
uh on the market and labor relations we
should add in there right yeah so so we
uh we encounter the products of our
labor which are kind of like objectified
social relations
on the market and we lose that sort of
direct personal dependency that you know
characterizes earlier eras
so um when
you know when when ponte here gives this
sort of classic
look at dialectical materialism
he kind of highlights that that
economics production is the basis of
the base and and that our history is
determined by by um
that is human history is determined by
the economic relations and the way those
are elaborated by the
relations of production that obtain on
top of them which is
includes sort of objectified social
relations
i think here it's actually worth
situating this a little bit in
intellectual context uh because one of
the big debates that were going on that
was going on in french marxist circles
at this point uh was how seriously to
take lucas's uh seminal reinterpretation
of dialectical materialism along more
hegelian lines uh and this has direct
bearing uh first of all like marlo ponte
since of course lukash's main argument
is precisely that the life world
presents itself as a kind of reified
entity uh that people are unable to
interact with and unable to change uh
they just have to kind of accept it
because it's been naturalized for them
and i don't think that molar ponte
is entirely critical of this idea but he
definitely argues that it's a retreat
back in some senses focusing on this
from
strict dialectical materialism in the
classical marxist sense since it focuses
a lot on the ideas in our head and how
the life world presents itself to
perception rather than the material
practices that we engage in
with our body and in interaction with
others
so it's a really important debate
historically right and when we say uh
these material practices he's he thinks
that this marxist way of interpreting
everything only via economics
is over determining a little bit our
interpretation of human history because
for sure
our interaction with the world is
economic in some senses but he's also
saying it's not just economic so
sort of like what he did when he's
saying descartes got this like half
right and then went a little bit too far
he's kind of saying the same thing with
marx's history which is you're not
actually paying attention to how
economics affects
somebody you make up this thing called
class consciousness class consciousness
is supposed to be like swirling around
us but we don't ever actually look at
the objects themselves
where do we get class consciousness from
and he goes into this a little bit
saying our interpretation of economics
is not
from you know sitting and reflecting on
it our interpretation of economics
happens when we go to the grocery store
and we see how much things cost
uh relative to how much we make or
when we are getting paid a certain
amount compared to
um our friend who we go out for lunch
with and he's getting paid a certain
amount so in each of these
direct interactions is when we feel um
economics
not as not as an abstract thing but as a
concrete thing and our
our sensibility towards revolution which
he he keeps bringing up the sensibility
towards revolution comes from
the buildup of those you know
uh molecular interactions not from
having some grand scope of history yeah
and i think it's also important to
stress here that while on the one hand
he's criticizing this location uh
hegelian marxism
which is quite sophisticated i should
say so i don't think we should just
dismiss it he's also criticizing another
kind of vulgar marxism uh that
emphasizes the materiality of human
beings yes uh but foreground's labor
as kind of the exclusively dominant
human power
or even tries to define all human
activity in terms of laboring and
creating our world
and ponte says absolutely there's no
doubt that laboring is a huge part of
what we do with our body
whether you're talking about you know
these kind of lock-ins in the state of
nature who are tilling their farms or
you talk about somebody in 20th century
france working at a factory but it's not
the only kind of
activity we engage in in a capitalist
society that's materially meaningful
there's also like pills that's pointing
out going to the store buying a
baguettes buying some cigarettes uh
sitting there talking about how there's
no meaning to life and scribbling that
down in nausea uh you know all this is
extremely important as well and it's
kind of missed uh by this vulgar marxism
which really runs the risk of almost
re-naturalizing uh the bourgeois man and
making the same mistake that a lot of
classical liberal theorists made which
is also to emphasize this notion that
who human beings are are laborers first
and foremost
that's a vulgar marxist take by the way
i don't think marx
actually believed that at all uh
although he could sometimes
get that sense from his early writings
if you don't look at them closely yeah
i'm not super familiar with the
hegelian interpretation of marxism
but yeah that you say that became
widespread
or at least influential when lukach put
it forward
and it was picked up by the frankfurt
school
where they they emphasize the sort of
subjective component as it exists sort
of against
nature you'd say like nature
is excluded from the historical
materialist dialectic
i mean this is some of the new
directions that like eco marxism is
thinking in any way is that you exclude
nature from the dialectic so nature
again just becomes this sort of
background against which humans conduct
their activities
and it's it's i mean from a more modern
perspective it's kind of
maybe problematic to to limit it that
way but it's a kind of it's one kind of
reduction anyway and then the other kind
of reduction is yeah sort of vulgar
materialist reduction of of
that
that somehow economic relations are
causal of of
of subjective
aspects of our you know of our life
world i guess you'd call it
that they're not
exclusively causal relations
that ponti mentions here
um they are they are it's it's more
i don't know i want to say just i want
to say descriptive
um
without
without
necessarily limiting it to like
husserl's version of phenomenology
um it's it's it's also interpretive i
guess after heidegger as well right his
sort of hermeneutic
variety that he introduces
and now what happened here i guess in
the context of of between heidegger and
and ponte is that existentialism became
a major movement with john paul sartre
and so he he wrote these series of
articles
sort of
misinterpreting
heidegger a little bit heidegger's focus
on dazine
and he misinterpreted this and said that
existentialism is a humanism
and this is something heidegger really
didn't like it was kind of a
misunderstanding between the two
um but for for better or worse it it
picked up steam
and so you have this sort of existential
interpretation of phenomenology
but ponte's pontes here is i i'm i'm not
i'm not actually not entirely sure how
it relates to sart's
version of existentialism
um well he kind of calls it
the same way that he goes between
intellectualism and empiricism like we
talked about last week he also comes
here between uh materialism and what he
calls spiritualism so he's not simply a
materialist
because he says like
the economic part of our life is but one
part of our life that's not the part
that just provides generates and
establishes all meaning it's important
but it's not the only one and then
spiritualism i can't i'm not exactly
sure who he's talking about when he is
saying spiritualism it sounds like um
hegel and and sart could both be accused
of that by saying this is about if like
history is about thought in some way not
about these interactions but he's going
to go right down the middle and say
you know what it's both you're both part
right if you just look at someone's life
the way they interact
the way they think about
their economic situation but also try to
find meaning you're just going to
realize that it's both
right so is it is it is kind of the
objection also like that especially
against i guess the first kind sorry
like the non-spiritualism
what was the other one is it just
materialism or what is it yeah it's
spiritualism i'll just read the quote
here history has no single signification
what we do always has several senses and
this is how how an existential
conception of history is distinguished
from both materialism and spiritualism
right okay so i think oh sorry
so i think like what's interesting about
that is that like i i also think this
relates to kind of um
like merlot ponti's interest in
resisting like rep like thinking about
things through representation because
because i feel like one of the things
he's doing especially on the like more
materialistic side is like
i think he's accusing of kind of just
reducing the world uh the life world
into just this kind of like
representation that like reduces
everything to these kind of like logical
um
economic relations
and like he doesn't want us to forget uh
about like the lived experience but at
the same time i think he's also worried
that like thinking about things through
the perspective of just like this lived
experience perspective also can mystify
because it like becomes i guess i'm what
i'm taking him to mean by spiritualism
could be wrong but that's kind of how
i'm
hearing it it's kind of like avoiding
just like reductive representationalism
but then avoiding like this over kind of
a raiification of like just like oh
lived experience is like this this thing
that you can't necessarily contain it's
like i think he wants to say you can
talk about it you can identify it but
you can't just like put it all under the
heading of like one or the other way of
thinking i guess i mean the way that i
read his spiritualism is again going
back to the kind of lucas point and i
think it's important to stress that at
the time it might seem a little bit
difficult to recognize in hindsight
lukaku is like the hottest [ __ ] in
marx's theory uh
lucian goldman wrote a book on camp
where i described lukacs heidegger and
kant along with marx's like the most
seminal thinkers uh of the modern era
which seems a little bit weird in
hindsight because one of those doesn't
really belong uh but you know lucox has
this defense of not just [ __ ] vision
which ponte is going to take very very
critically but also a kind of
teleological vision of history which is
that the rarefied life world will
eventually be overcome when we develop a
sufficiently refined class consciousness
that'll be a revolution it's pretty much
inevitable and we'll get something that
to lukash's mind will look a little bit
like the bolshevik state uh or at least
the bolshevik state as it could have as
it should have been uh and ponte is a
lot more critical of this saying that
this takes dialectics hegelian
dialectics with all the kind of
spiritualist undertones way way way too
seriously and undermines a lot of the
more materialist dimensions of marx
because of course this idealist
teleological vision of history says that
all we need to do is wait for hi class
consciousness to emerge break open the
real five life world and then we'll get
the bolshevik paradise that's awaiting
us and ponti is going to say absolutely
not right you can't just sit there and
expect class consciousness to
assume this kind of form over a long
enough period of time that's a kind of
spiritual or almost religious
orientation
you need to actually go out there and
put it really bluntly convince the
working classes uh that they're being
exploited that things are [ __ ] and that
there are ways of changing it uh
and you know that's a practical
political project and he spends a fair
bit of time actually writing about it
but i find that quite refreshing because
like a lot of people i do find these
kind of cheesy teleological visions of
history you find some vulgar marxists
put forward
really irritating uh
and have they have this kind of
religious quality to them you might be
on to something in that uh both he and
sarah attended kojev's
lectures
and kojev
has a kind of end of history thesis but
um more to the point this class
consciousness it's like if you go out
and just like convince people
as if that's the way that like human
existence works you need to be convinced
of things before you act that's wrong
here oh yeah that's that's just like
especially in that especially in the
second passage that you had us read
right like that that's like the main
thesis of those pages i think right so
people are going to react to things that
affect them they're not going to react
to ideas and this is i think
what we can we can tell our marxist
twitter friends
you don't just convince people and then
they suddenly
act in a certain way they're not going
to i love that they're not going to
revolt
because you told them ideas that's not
how that's not how this whole thing is
going to work one of pills
you're saying that if we don't just hand
out copies of the communist manifesto in
a factory uh we're going to get a
revolution tomorrow that's [ __ ] if i
handed out enough copies of the
communist manifesto give me five days
and we'll see the canadian state
overthrown man i wish i would call this
actually hand out papers because they
don't even do that you just tweet at
them calling them you know phil's i feel
like you should call this episode uh
like marxism and why ideas don't matter
because that's like one of your favorite
things you're one of your favorite
things to say pills all the time even
like yeah you'll say ideas don't matter
ideas don't matter why do you care about
ideas they don't matter and i feel like
here we go marilla pontin's saying
ideas i wasn't the first to say it um
and he's not saying they don't matter to
be fine
he's saying let's go through the middle
here
because
people are going to revolt
the revolutionary consciousness if we
want to call it that does not come from
convincing it comes from when you go to
the the grocery store and you can't
afford what's on the shelf that's where
that's where dissatisfaction and then
what we call class consciousness comes
from but he doesn't even like the term
class consciousness because it assumes
this this whatever miasma cochito that
as soon as people
like subjectively uh
give mental assent towards an idea then
they're gonna revolt and that's not how
it works well it's not it's you know
this thesis is not that dissimilar from
like kind of what heidegger says where
it's like you don't even notice the
object until it breaks it's like you
know you're not gonna actually notice
like the revolution until like your
world breaks and like something comes up
and you're like oh why is this [ __ ] so
expensive like [ __ ] this yeah you don't
you don't recognize your economic
conditions until you can't afford
something right yeah exactly i mean
jesus had a wonderful quote uh about the
arab spring back in 2011 quite some time
ago where he points out that what set
that off wasn't people distributing
revolutionary pamphlets it was just some
guy in tunis who was tired of having to
pay bribes to the government to sell his
fruit in front of the government
buildings so what did he do he went he
set himself on fire pretty dramatic
choice uh but then a lot of people just
got [ __ ] pissed off and they're like
you know what he's right uh and then
they smashed the government and replaced
it with a more republican one
and i think that's a real testament to
this kind of pontian wisdom right a lot
of people don't react because they're
handed a pamphlet or because they're
handed a set of ideas they get pissed
off at the material impact on their
lives of this policy or this practice or
whatever it happens to be and that's the
spark uh that lights the fire like right
i would say i did actually think about
that uh that arab spring when i was
reading reading this and you know it's
kind of consistent with some of the
stuff it's interesting i i kind of
forgot about this passage and in my own
work you know uh this is like fairly
consistent with how i'm using mira
laponte to talk about some
some other like um kind of like radical
democratic theory and like like kind of
vaguely anarchistic theories that i
think end up leaning on
ideas not in the same way anyway that's
like a bit of a bit of a tangent that i
don't necessarily want to go down but
like um what i like about this i think
that's
tangent actually if you want to
yeah yeah
why revolution is not just a decision
that we make on twitter you know yeah
and actually like so specifically
there's a part here on page 470 where
you know he says um
you know it's unlikely uh that the
russian peasants of 1917 explicitly set
them set for themselves the task of
revolution and the transformation of
property relations like and i think this
is important like specifically the idea
of like explicitly setting yourself for
the task like it's some like deliberate
deliberate
uh activity that you like you kind of
like have this idea oh revolution i want
that end goal
and i actually really like how in the
sentence right after that he says there
is no need for each proletarian to
conceive himself as a proletarian in the
sense a marxist theoretician gives this
word right so he's saying like you know
that doesn't matter you don't need to
think about you don't need to understand
any of this stuff it's going to kind of
happen and i think
um a lot of
radical theories um of kind of like
democratic participation that i find
somewhat objectionable they i think that
they implicitly require this kind of
like deliberate activity of like i'm
going to be a radical subject i'm going
to constantly be living in this
permanent revolution and setting myself
the task of being like this egalitarian
subject that is going to be like you
know engaged in political mobilization
all the time and it's like i think from
a marilyn pontian perspective like
that's just that that's a dead end that
doesn't go anywhere
i should also say that it's it's also
not really consistent with
the real history of radicalism even on
the sort of radicalism these people like
and the bolshevik revolution didn't take
place because people distributed copies
of lenin's what must be done to the
population uh it occurred in no small
part because of the first world war a
huge number of different uh factors
associated with that but also because
the bolshevik slogan was very simple it
was land
bread and peace yeah right that's what
motivated people not we need to
instantiate the revolutionary socialist
state in line with the teleology of
marx's dialectical history right nobody
would [ __ ] march well i think the
most important part was the actual
organizational activities that trotsky
and lenin were engaging in they were
organizing soviets which are those small
councils it's that kind of actual
activity that brought it about right
that was the conditions that were
established first not not simply
sloganing not not sloganeering not that
sort of hundredth monkey effect of how
ideas or behaviors spread in the kind of
mysterious way it was actual
organizational activities
that's what you that yeah and those and
those organisms and those organizational
activities were obviously reacting to
something like very perceptible in like
the life world i think like you're right
that like the kind of material
organization was crucial but i also
think like
to me i also feel that mira laponte
gives
some good theoretical material to
understand why that activity fizzled and
it transformed into something else
afterwards because it's like because
because that that activity has to be
responding to something that's present
and then all of a sudden it was
overthrown and then like
then they no longer there's no longer
like a present at hand
like reason or actually ready to hand
reason for why uh you need to be
engaging in this organizing activity now
it's like well we won we overthrew them
and then i think all that stuff just
gets sedimented and it kind of congeals
and becomes like no longer active in the
same way that like the account that i
think marilla ponte here is giving about
how this revolutionary action kind of
like depends on like the ready to hand
situation that's right in front of you
that you're reacting to kind of in a in
a vitalistic way it's like happening
right there and you're reacting and
you're organizing in response to that
but once that goes away i think that um
there's just all kinds of opportunity
for kind of like habit
uh the habit body and and other
relations to kind of just like decay
into something else yeah i'd like to i'd
like to reconnect this to our our
previous episode on this and just like
most of what most people do most of the
time is not
represented in their head with a goal
that's explicit most of it is this
body body intentionality
moving here moving there you're not
thinking about it explicitly and his
account of the of the russian revolution
is similar to that like sure people were
organized into soviets but why did they
leave their house in the first place
they left their house because something
else was wrong that they wanted to fix
and and not explicitly say i want to i
want to have a revolution in in russia
now lenin thought that
but
lenin didn't do the revolution by
himself right it was it was the material
bodily lived experiences of people that
were being exploited and and finally for
whatever reason it clicked that they
were being exploited and that's what got
them out of their houses yeah
well that's what i was getting at with
the peace land and bread slope yeah yeah
yeah i wasn't trying to apply something
cheesy like if the soviets and our
bolsheviks have chosen some shittier
slogan history would have been very
different if they had gone with
overthrow the bourgeois state uh people
would have decided to stay home what was
captured by the slogan you know peace
land and bread is that people were
materially suffering a great deal
because of the consequences of the first
world war the kinds of exploitation that
were present in their society were
extremely vivid
because the authoritarian
high-mindedness
with which the war was carried out
and as pills said i think that people
just finally clicked
and this slogan was powerful in part
because it connected with what they
really wanted at that point which is
food for everybody
land so there's a relative level of
equality in society and peace because
they don't want to have to keep throwing
their sons and daughters into a meat
grinder against the german war machine
they also wanted out of that
they also wanted out of the the the
wealthy landowner relationship right
they were it was a system of debt
slavery that that had set in near the
end of the 19th century for various
reasons this debt slavery situation it
wasn't just world war one that might
have been the catalyst but that was not
the sort of
cause right it's like the revolution
revolutionary activity is a long and
slow and painstaking process it's not
something that just kind of clicks into
place when the right sets of things come
together it's something that you have to
work towards and you have to plan for
and then obviously with the the
experiences of the bolshevik revolution
right it can go very wrong same thing
with the french revolution right ends up
in the great terror so something you
know one step forward two steps back
kind of thing but
but it's that long slow process in the
background as well that long overarching
process
so the question that he'd be interested
with respect to why did people leave
their house is
they saw in the world this is like the
merlot pontian
term world
it solicited them with possibility
so
at whatever time
they saw
this this this uh class relate well they
wouldn't call it because that's
representational but you know the class
relationship that i'm involved in i
don't have to
keep living like this and however that
possibility occurs is like the the brink
of of change at that point yeah i also
think that like the it's it's not only
are they perceiving possibilities but
but in a way it's like um the other word
i'm it's on the tip of my tongue but
it's like you know the the opposite of
like an invitation but it's almost like
if things get so bad i think that you
also see like um you know requirements
on action right like you perceive you're
pulled and you're like well i like what
else am i gonna do it's like you have to
act like you know yeah um and i have
nothing else to lose at that point yeah
and i also also
mark's captured that beautifully where
he said you know the workers have
nothing to lose but their chains right
yeah exactly evocatively captures
exactly the sentiment that you're trying
to get but i also wanted to kind of kind
of say something that i kind of just
noticed as as we were talking like a
little bit before
that i think what's funny is that you
could maybe make a marilla pontian
argument for accelerationism
because like because you need to make
the condition so bad that people's like
like that people's like life world
changes that they're like that they're
pushed in action uh
because like you're not going to
convince them with ideas
you're not going to convince like you're
not going to get changed so it's like
you have to make things so bad now i
don't
i don't i don't want that like that's
not a view that i would support i just
think it's kind of amusing that i think
that there's a possibility that i'm
detecting here for an accelerationist
mir lapontine account of revolution
let's just see if i understand you right
the way to solve our our environmental
crisis contra eric is to pollute the
environment so recklessly well depends
what kind of no it depends on the kind
of the breaking point it depends on the
kind of accelerationism we're talking
about what i more had in mind was like
you know
like wishing for worse policies that
like that exact like you want to make
the income inequality worse and worse
and worse so that like at some point we
could get to a point where
you know um i mean i obviously don't
support that but it's kind of funny that
you can stop
i'm gonna stop recycling right now i'm
gonna [ __ ] use oil for everything i
can gonna go make a gasoline fire rate
tonight it's like let's kick capitalism
into hyperdrive or if we can't go around
it we're going to go through the
[ __ ] yeah you heard it this is a
call for all leftists everywhere to
advocate for the total deregulation of
uber amazon seriously people are not
going to actually uh you know uh just
just like if things aren't
things aren't bad enough
no no i get what you're saying i i
wasn't intending to be mirthful about
that it was just something like
something we were talking about last
night
one thing that he does say in the in the
second section that i gave to you is
that like he has you have to see
something worse
almost quickly to be able to break a
habit it has to it has to uh
the conditions have to worse worsen very
quickly because otherwise you just kind
of get used to them
but as soon as you see like
my life is worse than my parents life
like the faster that that happens the
more you're gonna think like i can act
to change this otherwise if it's just
like everyone slowly becomes an amazon
employee
over like i'm curiosity
i don't care also does that mean he's
being a little bit unfair to sartre i
mean i'm all for
kicking transcendental narcissism that's
we put it down a couple pigs
but sergeant did have this wonderful
evocative comment where i once said he
never felt freer than when he was in a
nazi prisoner camp pow camp really
because under those kind of
circumstances he realized that every
kind of gesture and act he made had
extraordinary significance as an
expression of his freedom
and if he hadn't been put in that kind
of condition and was just going through
his everyday life in a kind of
normalized life world
the importance of the individual act
wouldn't have been as transparent to him
so i mean
he puts it more poetically in nasa but
that's kind of general idea and it seems
to have this ponte and quality to it if
that's what you're aiming for
merlot ponte is quite critical of sart's
marxism because
well i i think sartre actually said i'm
i'm not a marxist i'm a i'm an anarchist
but merlo ponti's
sense of sart his criticism of sarp um
in adventures of the dialectic is that
he
he thinks all contingency is bad
the only thing that he wants to
overthrow is contingency to have this
radical sense of freedom and i'm i'm
guessing if don't you mean overthrow
necessity or no like
no contingency like that the previous
actions are why things are the way they
are now
oh okay okay i got you all right go
ahead and he said that's that's just not
how any human
how the human life works i think that
might be what he's calling spiritualism
because
so much of what we do i keep using this
term 95
95
is related to
habit it's not explicit i'm free here's
my actions like sart is still going to
take shits you know
yeah exactly and i think also the reason
why sometimes we don't realize how much
of it is kind of like habit and like
response and kind of like
respond to the situation that is kind of
unconscious is because often when we
think about our past actions we apply
kind of like post talk like
rationalizations for like why we did the
thing right like we often think about it
it's like oh i did that because i
decided to do this but it's like if you
think about it deeply enough you realize
that like in the moments you're kind of
just reacting uh
okay i do get that i mean it sounds
almost like a borjez uh plot in some
senses because i do understand that like
if you really had to deliberate upon
taking any kind of action
and asking yourself is this truly what i
want to do as an expression of my
freedom life would become unbearable so
in some senses ponti's argument for
habit and the persistence of habit is
really a relief because the fact that we
do so many things habitually and not
deliberately um frees up a lot of our
cognitive time to focus on other things
would that be the way that you put it
yeah and paradoxically i think you're on
to something there because it does also
create conditions of of a kind of
freedom because we are like because we
are released
from like the deliberate the
deliberative requirement of every action
we are actually free to kind of like be
and that's actually why a lot of merlot
pontians
like do like talk about like music and
marilyn ponty talks about musical
instruments and kind of like the way
your body gets absorbed into the act of
like music creation and jazz the the
improvisation is like almost unconscious
you're in but it allows for tremendous
amount of freedom right like like if you
had to like deliberately consciously
think oh i'm gonna play this note i'm
gonna like the creative potential would
be gone like like you just couldn't you
couldn't do anything like like your body
has to be like absorbed into the action
in a way that where you're like where
your body kind of takes over for you and
there's like this kind of like
i don't know you can use all kinds of
evocative language to describe that
process but it's kind of a freedom in
the not having to think rationally about
it no no i get that i mean i really like
the sartre
analogy about feeling free in a pow camp
yeah because even if it's problematic it
does have this kind of
evocative quality to it but i absolutely
agree that it almost sounds like a
forehead story it like fumes the
memories uh if i were having to sit
there being like do i want to move my
foot forward will i move my foot forward
going to take the next step should i do
that right uh that would be an
unbearable kind of life uh and it would
mean all my mental activity is focused
on things that are really pretty
pedantic uh that would almost want to be
automated uh and free of my clients or
imagine or i remember talking about this
in a niche seminar um when we were
talking about like thought and i think
it speaks to tamara laponte like imagine
how horrifying would be if you had to
decide to have a thought
right so like you're like i'm gonna have
that i'm gonna decide to allow that
thought to come into my head and it's
like you had to go through this process
of like
of like deciding to have thoughts every
time you have a thought like that's a
[ __ ] nightmare well i mean to be fair
i do know what that experience is like
because i once ate a whole plate uh full
of brownies uh and started tripping out
and i was like don't think about that
don't think oh my god i am thinking
about that no no no no no don't think
about that it was just a horrible cycle
and everything went downhill from there
so believe me the pontia nightmare uh is
real so it's it's interesting if we're
uh
starts mode of freedom is i can think
of whatever i want therefore i am free
and that's merely ponte has a half a
third of this book is on freedom but
it's not that kind of freedom it's not i
just think i can think whatever i want
it's like your body affords you
free possibilities and i think uh the
musical instrument example is a
perfect one because that
makes you free to play that instrument
and that's not like affordances as you
were saying yeah and while if you're
good at an instrument you're probably
thinking about something else while
you're playing you know and it's but
that the freedom comes from
um being so familiar with these
different aspects of the world that
that you can use them use uh be creative
you have these capacities to be with
this mit sign in the world
that is uh not not intellectual it's not
intellectualized in the way that that
starts like i can i can think about
whatever i want if i go to a cafe i'm
free to wonder if pierre is there or not
et cetera et cetera yeah there's that
that interesting example that sartre
gives of of
freedom free like ex radical existential
freedom
a famous example of the person who's
whose brother was killed in the war
and they want to join the army and go
and avenge him but the person also lives
with their mother
and if they're to leave their mother
alone
something really awful might happen to
her right she might be she might become
depressed or kill herself or get killed
or something like that so you're faced
with this impossible decision
and you it's too sort of options that
you cannot weigh against each other
there's no rational calculus you can
apply to it to make the decision for you
you have to make the decision yourself
and so you're radically free in the
sense that either option it's down to
you you decide which one to do but if
you want to try and figure out which
question is the right or which answer is
the right one there's no way to do that
because again that would imply the
responsibility isn't yours the
responsibility is you applying some kind
of rational or decision making framework
whatever it is cost benefit analysis all
that [ __ ] you have to make the
choice and you're radically free to do
it but each choice could [ __ ] you over
in some way and that's the sort of
contingent aspect of being free in the
existential sense
faced with impossible opposition
opposites like that
yeah i saw i read this wonderful uh book
that talked about this in the context of
the nazi occupation of greece uh where
apparently there was a scenario where
there were revolutionary fighters hiding
in a town
and so the ss captured one of these
revolutionary fighters then lined
everyone else up in the town
uh and told the guy if you don't reveal
to us which one of these is your comrade
we're just gonna shoot everybody uh
every single person in the town uh and
the revolutionary said fat freedom is
more important and then the ss killed
everybody and one of the questions that
kind of emerged from this is was this
the right thing to do uh to defy the ss
officer at the price of the life of all
these people uh and the point that the
person was trying to make from a kind of
searching perspective is there's no way
of actually making that kind of judgment
call
through a formal calculus you just have
to kind of decide what kind of thing
you're going to prioritize in this
instance and what kind of person you're
willing to be
understanding that you [ __ ] either way
and you're gonna have to bear the
responsibility of that
so i find these kinds of certain
conceptions of freedom at least
evocative and poetic uh
i agree that pontius is a lot more
philosophically rich but i think from a
novelistic perspective he's always very
talented
so how do we chart in a sense that
decision that i
sort of outlined in relation to sart
comes up here in the ponte reading as
well uh you know that choice between
between
economics and materialism or
spiritualism
and that's almost like if if we're if we
want to i don't know if we he says we
have to choose between these two
positions
but not really because he has he has
then he's going to reveal this different
way of understanding them that makes the
sort of decision disappear in a certain
way
but in a sense he presents spiritualism
and materialism as choices
we have to make you know do you want to
work in the realm of ideas or do you
want to work in the realm of of
of i don't know keying keying your
actions to guiding history according to
according to economic conditions and and
and what sorts of
revolutionary struggles are going to
become relevant in that context
yeah it's it's very much a parallel of
his critiques of
you know cartesianism on one hand and
empiricism on the other is you can't
just go all the way in one direction
like sarts starts talking about
revolution like it's this spontaneous
free
action that people are going to
undertake and then that's kind of what
he advocated for
whereas
um
i don't know a scientific economic
marxism is just going to say this is
only material but and it's just it seems
so obvious i guess in hindsight to be
like
of course it's not one of the other i
agree i mean the weird thing is despite
his criticisms
this kind of fetishism of the almost
religious or apocalyptic quality of
revolution is still very prevalent in
some major thinkers uh i mean all you
need to do is read al ambigio on
revolution uh where he calls it a
disruption in the order of being that
cannot be predicted uh but when it
emerges you either choose to show
fidelity do it or you don't uh to
realize that there's a really religious
quality to this uh now whatever it is
that you think about that i think that
rural ponte is a lot more realistic and
grounded uh where he says no religions
uh religions revolutions don't just
emerge spontaneously as these kinds of
events in the order of being it takes a
huge amount of work much of which is
going to be incredibly mundane and you
can't even count on just inspiring
people by ideas to change things because
you actually need to be able to show
them or they need to be able to see all
the [ __ ] up things in the world around
them uh before they're gonna be
motivated to action well also maybe
maybe to just add a little nuance to
that i think that like it's not so much
that um i think that like the
spontaneity of revolutions
to marry like i think it exists in
marilla ponte because it's like gonna
occur from like the lived experience but
it's only really going to seem
spontaneous to those who aren't affected
by the revolution like everyone who
right like like they're experiencing the
world and how shitty it is and they see
the clear reasons for why they would be
angry but it just seems spontaneous to
an outsider who's like you know i guess
like a capitalist who's not involved you
know for example yeah i have a perfect i
have a perfect quote of that is when
like when he's talking about this vision
of spontaneous revolution he says that
people are talking about the other you
know the pure negation he might as well
have been writing too bad you even
though this was written
40
40 years before being an event but he
says uh merlot ponti says marx was able
to have and to transmit the illusion of
a negation realized in history and in
its matter only by making the
non-capitalistic future an absolute
other but we who have witnessed a
marxist revolution well know that
revolutionary society has its weight its
positivity and is therefore not the
absolute other
so this weight and positivity that he's
talking about is that
huge stack of lived experiences that
caused the revolution in the first place
if you're looking at history as this
dialectic from the outside then it seems
like you i mean you could you could
conceive that this is just a spontaneous
other event not related to what happened
before totally non-contingent but then
you're forgetting the life world
again yeah
there's a fun comparison that ponte
makes there too right because
you know think about when you're when
you're healthy and you're going through
your life right and you see somebody
who's sick right and they're they're
like oh sorry guys i can't come out
tonight i'm i'm not feeling great i'm
gonna stay in bed and everyone who's
healthy is like well [ __ ] this guy what
an idiot like why why are you why are
you missing out but
ponti compares illness to revolution it
says that says that history only presses
closer to economics when the revolution
approaches just as
just as uh you are pressed closer to the
vital rhythms of your body when you get
sick
so somebody who's not sick in that sense
wouldn't understand the sort of vitality
that revolution taps into right that
it's like an illness that's happening
and and then again you only see the the
economic rhythms of history
they only show through as the sickness
gets worse as the revolution approaches
and then until then history and
economics seem like perfectly separate
things right and he seems to think that
so then
in those times of of you know relative
quiet right they separate and history
becomes the realm of ideas right the
history of ideas and and and then i
think maybe that's bourgeois
that's that's bourgeois spiritualism and
then on the other hand everything is
economics right so then that becomes the
sort of
the sort of vulgar marxism and you have
that materialist side so you have this
split between again spiritualism and
materialism spiritualism is the kind of
conservative
backwards looking bourgeois side whereas
materialism is the forward looking and
we can't see how they're related until
[ __ ] hits the fan basically until the
illness
hits until the revolution comes and then
we see how interdependent they are and
how silly the opposition is in the first
place i got this guy just he just
[ __ ] nails it does he not that's like
this is just killer
merlot yeah he does he does nail i don't
actually i i i i wanted to like there's
such a great quote uh just like
on page 473 where he's talking about
like being an individual and so he says
you know at the outset i'm not an
individual above class i am situated
socially and my freedom even if it has
the power to commit me elsewhere does
not have the power to turn me
immediately into what i decide to be
thus being bourgeois or or a worker is
not merely being conscious of so being
it is
it is to give myself the value of a
worker or a bourgeois uh through an
implicit existential project that merges
with our way of articulating the world
and of coexisting with others um and
then he says my decision takes up a
spontaneous sense of life that it can
confirm or deny but that it cannot a
null um so anyway that's i think that's
like a nice like sum up i feel like of
kind of like the view he's trying to to
push forward here yeah and i mean
real quick real quick because uh victor
victor's got to go oh yeah
but can victor the quotation that you
read what's he i i i was trying to
follow along and i don't have the book
open but is he saying that we are
members of classes but you don't have to
be conscious of being a member of a
class to be in a class or what is the
point of that
well i think the point that i i took
away from it was like you know he does
it like you don't have the power uh
through like thought to just like decide
to be that thing but rather it's like an
interplay between um like merging like
the world that you're experiencing with
other people and this existential
project um and like you you can't just
like decide even though you have the
power to commit yourself so like
you can commit yourself to the to the
conditions that are in front of you
but like you can't just like decide to
be like oh i am a member of this
bourgeois it's like it's like it has to
it has to cohere i guess um with this
what he calls existential project um but
yeah it is a little bit it is a little
bit um
you know ambiguous maybe well i mean
that's just inter subjectivity he's like
replacing it replacing class a little
bit with not just like labor relations
but it's also an intersubjective uh
there's yeah and actually like right
right after that quote you know he says
idealism and objective thought and by
the way i don't know if we mentioned
this in previous episodes but objective
thought is really just the name that
mira laponte gives to those two views we
were talking about in the last two
podcasts intellectualism and empiricism
those two together is what he calls
objective thought um so he says idealism
and objective thought equally missed the
arrival of class consciousness the first
because it deduces actual existence from
consciousness the other because it
derives consciousness from actual
existence and both of them because they
are unaware of the relation of
motivation
so that's kind of interesting
um so class consciousness is unconscious
yeah well
i think he's trying to say that i think
he's try again as mayor luponte is
always going to do he's kind of trying
to locate that space in the middle uh
you know to say like you know it's not
really one or the other both of you are
missing something but anyway that was a
great discussion so i don't know i can
just say uh
thanks guys good discussion and then if
you want you could edit that until like
the end if you want victor victor's
gotta go teach
no we don't have we don't have to hide
the fact that you have to go teach you
know you have to go teach aristotle's
politics in two minutes literally i have
my zoom open uh so i will i will go and
start that alright see you dude all
right whip them whip them good
yeah i will also like to point out that
i think that his view is a lot closer to
a genuine kind of marxist perspective uh
like a robust philosophical marxism uh
because there's kind of vulgar marxist
millenarianism uh that you'll sometimes
see in people like badger i should point
out uh whereas this is there's this idea
that a revolution is necessarily going
to be again this event in the order
being you can't understand it and it's
going to transform everything and marx
never actually believed that in fact in
the critical gotham program he was very
explicit about the fact that we need to
understand revolution dialectically we
also need to recognize that any new
society that emerges is going to be as
he put it stamped with features of the
old one
because you can't just have this
attitude of we're going to throw
everything aside and then rebuild from
scratch that's not the way that history
works uh history is defined by material
relations and matter always just changes
uh form rather than being destroyed or
fundamentally transformed
so i think that ponti is really on the
nose here and trying to revive the more
sincere concept of marxist revolution
from its kind of
fetishization in a lot of french radical
theory i just want to say that i
genuinely think that
this materialist account of
phenomenology is much more to my taste
than some of the other
more idealist tinged flavors um
that i've been exposed to in the past
and that i've been quite critical of
including in my new book and i happen to
think that yeah matt i wanted to ask you
that you you kind of sounded like you're
accusing phenomenology of being a little
bit solipsistic did this change your
mind at all about that changed my mind
about this
version of phenomenology so if you
wanted to say am i on team or la ponte
the answer would be yes am i on team
phenomenology uh it would be i'm on team
merlot ponte's phenomenology not on
heidegger's uh phenomenology or team
horseshoes nominology so
yes with caveats
the sense that i'm getting from going
through this by the way this book is
1945. this is so underrated
definitely i agree
i mean it's a great book and it's so
like this does not this does not get the
citations that it deserves for sure
first he starts off by just saying all
of philosophy up until now is wrong and
here's why and then ends with like
marxist
marxist future phenomenology and an
account of freedom
yeah absolutely and i mean the nice
thing about this book also uh that you
don't usually find in masterpieces and
philosophy is that
you can never say that he's not really
fair to every side of the argument in
fact one of the things that i found
annoying about reading the book the
first time i went through it is you
sometimes think like wow that's really
convincing and then you realize oh he's
talking about intellectualism and why
it's wrong
oh [ __ ] but it's good because just like
wow this is such a convincing and
plausible account of intellectualism
that it almost manages to convert me
before he's like ah no not quite uh
we're gonna have to look at it from
somewhat different angle um and i really
think that a lot of people could learn
from that method because very few people
are as capable of being critical uh
while being so charitable as ponti and
it's kind of exhaustive right uh deliz
writes in uh
or he was writing an ode to sartre i
think after uh start died and he kind of
like hand waves merlou ponti for being
too professorial and and writing kind of
the way that you just said
yeah he didn't he didn't get the uh the
oomph the here's why this matters the
quippy lines the things that people like
about sartre
but like
and this is obviously what 600 pages but
it's so good
i think this method of writing is pretty
brilliant you know building up the the
argument that you're then going to argue
against a lot of a lot of writers just
sort of
reference what they're arguing against
and don't use the space that they're
writing in to you know actually set up
exactly what they're going to argue
against and ponte ponti has this
brilliant way of doing that of evoking
and almost making you convinced by the
thing that he's going to be you know
talking about and then and then and then
lo and behold he's like actually i have
this totally other way of understanding
things you're like oh like that's it's a
really an interesting rhetorical
strategy i like i haven't seen it since
like he he writes a sixth of the book on
how great descartes is
and then finishes up the section by
saying how descartes is like the worst
philosopher that ever lived
yeah
anyway great great stuff um so yeah this
is uh part three of phenomenology on the
pillpot i also did some
hour i think there are like hour and a
half long videos on on it um lectures
while i was going through this book but
i i i'm enjoying it
so we should uh
do a few more of these yeah 100 let's do
it
let's keep it up all right this has been
uh pillpon 60-something and uh
i will talk to you dudes later bye
[Music]
adios
[Music]